in his final moments shinzo abe was in
his elements campaigning for his party
[Music]
when two gun blasts rang out as the
camera settles the gunman is seen being
wrestled to the ground
highlighted from another angle the
attacker is seen approaching
then plumes of gunsmoke are let off at
close range our bay is hit in the back
and the neck
as the former prime minister lies on the
ground
there is chaos and confusion
[Music]
before he's airlifted to hospital
where doctors fought in vain to save him
you know
was japan's longest-serving best-known
and most important post-war prime
minister a familiar face among others on
the world stage giving japan a new
global role and stronger economy back
home
he was as important to japan and in
changing japan and changing japan's
standing in the world as margaret
thatcher was to
the uk or maybe ronald reagan was to
the united states the police say a
suspect in his 40s has been arrested
this is the weapon apparently a homemade
[Music]
in musket
country with some of the strictest gun
laws in the world with only one gun
related death last year there is utter
shock at the killing
especially because it was in the middle
of an intersection people can surround
you so there was no escape for mr arby
there's absolutely fault with the
liberal democratic party for making him
hold an election speech there
i didn't think mr abe was that bad of a
person so i thought did you have to go
so far as to kill him
in a message the queen said i have fond
memories of meeting mr arbei and his
wife during their visit to the united
kingdom in 2016.
his love for japan and his desire to
forge ever closer bonds with the united
kingdom were clear
the prime minister tweeted utterly
appalled and saddened to hear about the
despicable attack on shinzo abe
shinzo abe stood down as prime minister
because of ill health two years ago but
remained a powerful figure campaigning
for his party and pushing for a more
assertive stronger japan where his
influence and force of personality will
be sorely missed dominic waghorn sky
news